at the beginning of the 21st narration
reading 9 out of every 10 hold this is
like a really do game opening case it's
massive profits are generated by
military technology genetic
experimentation and viral weaponry so
basically just like Waffle House this is
supposedly a sealed room as we're told
later by one of the doctors who's about
the ground so I'm gonna take a wild
guess and say that this distribution of
the virus through the air conditioning
is impossible are we supposed to believe
that the dogs know there's a virus in
the air the Red Queen which was built to
be anal about well everything is just
now noticing this book wait just a damn
minute
this guy's coffee stain is not only
dried on record time but it also shrunk
and changed shaped significantly you can
totally see these pretend secure doors
bending outward when this guy pushes
against them meaning all that delicious
tea virus would be leaking out all over
the place why is this mysterious camera
building computer things so evil can I
not just gas the people in the elevator
like the rest without violently
beheading this one I get that this is a
shower curtain lying in the shower with
her but where the was it hanging from it
is in no way long enough to have been
hanging from something outside the top
of the shot voyeuristic umbrella company
fails to capture Alice changing into
this red dress she doesn't remember
anything at all about her past but she
does remember the laughter that plastic
is to her right
not behind her so why would she or the
audience believe that that's what she
saw in the reflection of the frame ooh
birds are scary why do I get the feeling
that if I played the video games I'd
know what the fuck was going on and why
does that piss me off ah the old classic
random bunch of metal bars hanging in
the middle of the train car storage
tactic no one could possibly get impaled
by one of those things later could that
the mansion above us you mean the
mansion you left in a train a minute ago
that mansion is no longer above you your
marriage
I mean honestly what's the point in
spending the first 20 minutes
deliberately confusing the pet of the
viewer if you're planning to fill in all
the gaps with a textbook expositional
speech at the end of it all and we're
back inside the video game cutscene
again wonderful oh man I hope this
camera move doesn't mean what I think it
means
what an asshole checkmate human taunts
homicidal Red Queen computer the first
laser is pretty deadly if you're over 6
feet tall and have no reaction time oh I
see this neck one to the underworld
school of revealing itself to the
audience why didn't it just do this in
the first place
also this laser is racist hey thanks for
the heads up Alice a little whisper
would have sufficed super high-tech AI
computer can be controlled by wrist PDA
yes she's a holographic representation
of the Red Queen modeled after the head
programmers daughter the head programmer
thinks his daughter is creepy anything
to stop us from shutting her down like
appearing as an all red digital computer
voice child which I don't know about you
but that always plucks my heartstrings
wait how do the emergency lights survive
the EMP or these lights so after the
power went out and the green lights all
turned red and these boxes now say
environment unstable they all just
stayed here okay zombies everyone get in
a single-file carnac line so that you
could be blown away like a carnival
attraction absolutely no one dies from
this huge explosion in the closed space
that is definitely not possible
the real enemy of this movie is the CGI
there are clearly zombies everywhere and
then they open the door and they're
islamics everywhere in there and they
steal it who'd need them but then we cut
away to the CGI beast and then BAM
somehow these guys got away and her in a
safe enough place to argue when you cut
the power you unlock the doors you let
them out this guy did exactly what the
mission called for would you have done
any different would you have been like
hey whoa whoa there might be a lot of
zombies down here don't shut the power
off
Alice decides to snoop around the
facility after a zombie attack and
continues to do so even when she sees
that what was this bastard doing the
whole time Alice was walking around
outside nearly the entire zombie payroll
came down to eat the military team when
the doors open is this the one dude who
said nah I'll just wait until someone
locks herself in this room with me well
right these azam bees weren't dying when
getting shot and now a kick does one of
them in no devil dogs were harmed in the
making of the scene she had a contact
within the hive someone I never met that
access to security coded surveillance
she told me all that but she didn't tell
me anything about what the person looked
like or what their name was when did
this happen
one minute they're giving us exposition
now
the sudden they're running for their
lives a homicidal bitch killed my team
oh so now you're okay with her being
shut down even in death the human body
still remains active Heron thinking has
continued to grow misconception and the
brain itself holds a small electrical
charge today I think my favorite part of
this movie used the 10 minutes section
where they talk to the computer every
one of them heard the Red Queen say that
being bitten turns you into one of the
zombies but none of them have any issue
with the obviously bitten Michelle
Rodriguez still tagging along with a
group after that large crowds of hungry
zombies are quiet until the last minute
so that they can create jump scares yeah
break that arm that's how you finish him
off hungry zombies who only know that
they are hungry never once try to go up
to rain while she fishes for her gum or
when she's just standing there looking
at JD JD is a zombie but rain the first
person we saw get bit is totally not a
zombie I don't want to bore you with the
details of my miraculous escape but I
totally fought off that horde of zombies
that was blocking the way up here what
the hell is this place it's some sort of
maintenance area with electrical tubing
everywhere so why the cage what does
this cage do other than inconveniently
block someone when they're trying to get
away from zombies
what is his final destination want you
to go
no not leaving you Kaplan leave me
behind I'm not leaving you behind cliche
cheese why did he just do this before
now she's puking and turning pale yet
these stupid bastards are still acting
like zombies not a foregone conclusion
there's a cure you're gonna be okay I
was beginning to worry honestly you're
just at the mercy of the screenwriter at
this point wow this is a whole thing
stop pile of convenient memories
flooding back to him at once
also this is in no way the same note
that Alice saw earlier jeez dude you
just found out you're the bad guy and
you've already started acting out bad
guy tropes I wouldn't want to shoot
Janne like Nate the bullets soundy
approaching in two feet of standing
water makes no noise whatsoever any
reason to keep them alive no okay
just chatter discount Benham does the
brain monster with no eyes no there's a
camera behind him I don't wanna be one
of those things
quite honestly you've been bitten for
nearly an hour of movie time and you've
got bit in a second time it's totally
thing out of this world amazing that
you're not already a zombie Oh No who's
our female protagonist gonna fall in
love with now what we really need to see
right now is a slow-motion bullet that
hits its target and is completely
ineffective oh look the pipes came in
handy after all if she's a zombie now
with no real brain function why does she
still do that signature Michelle
Rodriguez neck crack bang if there's a
countdown timer in a movie you can
guarantee you they're gonna make it just
in time ding umbrella you guys were
really confident a sequel worried
multipass little Dallas multipass to
multibus one does five on one hi
alright what would you
ah
some come hi I'm Sarah McLaughlin